it's really easy to set up auto scaling
on your google cloud managed instance
groups the configuration options offer
lots of flexibility to help fit your
application's needs let's dive a little
deeper into auto scaling and check out
three things that will help you set up
effective auto scaling on your instance
groups
[Music]
to implement more effective auto scaling
it's helpful to understand how it
generally works
the auto scaler monitors your instance
group and offers a size recommendation
that's a calculated number of vms needed
to serve the peak load over the last 10
minutes
these 10 minutes are referred to as the
stabilization period
this stabilization period is 10 minutes
so the auto scaler can ensure that usage
info that it uses to scale in and out is
stable and that helps prevent the auto
scaler from adding and removing machines
at an excessive break
when scaling back down it's able to
determine the smaller group size will be
able to support the peak load so that it
can safely remove instances
when auto scaling is turned on the
number of vms it scales your instance
group up and down to will be limited by
the minimum and maximum number of vms
that you specify when scaling in the
number of vms it can remove is also
limited by the scale in controls if
specified
if you configure auto scaling and leave
it turned off it still calculates
recommendations so you can see what the
auto scaler would do if it's turned on
without having to spin up additional
machines in the process
this way you can see the effects it'll
have before actually committing to them
so now that you know a little bit about
how it works here are three things to
consider when designing your auto
scaling configuration thing number one
the machine type okay so technically
this isn't part of the auto scale
configuration you actually indicate the
machine type on the instance template
associated with your instance group
but that's why it's so important for
auto scaling a new instance of that type
will be provisioned when the instance
group is scaled up
you might be thinking well yeah of
course but this is when knowing your
application is key for example if you
know that your application that you're
running on your instance group needs two
virtual cpus then e2 standard 2 has got
you covered
but if you also know that the same
application doesn't need much memory
then e2 high cpu 2 offers the same
number of virtual cpus with less memory
choosing that one means that every time
you scale your instance group out you're
not scaling out or paying for resources
that you won't be using
okay thing two
the cooldown period for effective auto
scaling you want to make sure you
specify an accurate cooldown period
the cooldown period is the
initialization time the amount of time
it takes for your application to
initialize after the host vm has been
provisioned
you want to be sure that you have an
accurate one specified
if you specify a cooldown period that's
too long then your auto scaler will miss
out on that utilization data and
potentially underestimate the required
size of your group
on the flip side if you specify a
cooldown period that's shorter than it
takes for your application to be ready
then it's possible for the auto scaler
to get inaccurate utilization data
because in some cases cpu utilization
while things are getting up and running
is higher and isn't a reflection of
normal use finally there's thing three
scaling controls
the ability for your managed instance
group to scale is a big win for reducing
costs
but you don't want to take a hit in
performance when you do that
scaling controls let you slow things
down by establishing a rate that the
auto skiller will scale down at this way
you'll be able to avoid dramatic drops
in group size remember that cooldown
period i just mentioned before
if your cooldown period is on the long
side by using scaling controls you'll
have the added benefit when there's a
sudden spike in demand you'll already
have machines available and you can
avoid delays caused by long
initializations
setting up the right scaling controls
just like choosing the right machine and
accurate cooldown period all comes down
to knowing your application its
requirements and expected load and
behavior
let's take a look at this managed
instance group that i've set up on
google cloud project here's a few things
about my configuration
i've set my minimum instances to 2 and
my maximum to 100 when i set this up i
wasn't sure about cooldown period so i
left it at the default value of 60
seconds
i wasn't sure about scaling controls so
i left that disabled
the instance template uses an e2
standard 2.
let's see how we can make changes to
this configuration let's edit my manage
instance group called web app instance
group and check out the auto scale
settings
we've got a regional managed instance
group so right off the bat i want to
take advantage of high availability by
making sure that i've got at least one
instance in each of my zones
that's three zones so i'll increase my
minimum to three
now that i'm here i also want to make
sure that my maximum is set to a
reasonable number
although it may be unlikely for my
application to need to scale that high
it's still possible for it to go as high
as 100.
for my application this is too much so
let's lower that to 30. it takes the
application of my virtual machine two
minutes to be ready so i'll set the
cooldown period to 120 seconds
that's pretty long so i'm going to
enable scaling controls in case i get
any spikes when my group is scaling down
in this case my instance group won't
scale down by more than 10 vms from the
peak size as observed over the prior 10
minutes
i'm going to save these settings for now
before i change one more thing
the vm type specified in the template is
an e2 standard 2 but that's got more
memory than i need so let's see how i
can replace that with an e2 high cpu2
instead
rather than clicking edit on my instance
group i can instead go up here to update
vms
up top here it says the current size of
my instance group
and the name of the template i use to
create the instances in it
here under new template i could add a
second template and roll that out to
only a certain percentage of my instance
group
this is one way to do a b testing or
deploy a canary of my application in
this case i want to replace my only
template with a different one that i
created for this demonstration with one
template specified my target size is 100
of my instance group down here under
update configuration i can specify how
i'd like the template to be rolled out
by selecting automatic the manage
instance group will proactively tear
down and replace each of my instance
group's instances created with the old
template here where it says temporary
additional instances i can specify how
many machines beyond the recommended
number can be provisioned to make this
transition possible this makes it
possible to maintain the recommended
number of vms while still tearing down
and recreating them
down here at the bottom is an update
summary that recaps configuration i set
for this update
once i'm finished i can kick this update
off using the equivalent command line or
rest api calls
otherwise i can just click update vms
here
the auto scaling offer to manage
instance groups is very flexible
the cooldown period and scaling controls
are a great start to setting up
effective auto scaling
also don't forget to choose a properly
sized vm on your instance template
beyond that there's much more you can
learn from the documentation to make
sure that your auto scaling is working
for you efficiently effectively and
affordably to learn more check out this
link for more on auto scaling and check
out the link in the description for
another demo on auto scaling
thanks for watching
[Music]
you